hey guys this is the report I'm
still Dave Rubin I've got Lisette Padilla
Kim Horcher with me we have a tremendous
amount of paper
on this desk that means we know what
we're talking about so let's get right
to it
obviously the big story this week is the
prisoner swap we got back
sergeant Bowe Bergahl from Afghanistan
in exchange for five Taliban prisoners
from Guantanamo Bay
there is all kinda stuff going on that
by the time we post this will probably
change
there's some question as to whether sick
soldiers actually died while looking for
him he may have been a deserter and had
not been captured actually
all kinda stuff but i wanna talk about
this a jeffrey toobin on CNN he is their
legal analyst I often don't agree with
him on a lot of stuff
usually that the NSA but he's saying the
president Obama
actually broke the law by not going to
congress before
a authorizing the prisoner release let's
take a look
you look at the law you look at the
signing statement you've gone through it
did the president break the law by your
engaging in this deal so I think he
clearly worked a lot be the law
says 30 days notice you can give 30 days
notice
now it is true that he issued a signing
statement but signing statements are not
lost signing statements are the
president's opinion
about what the law should mean
now it may be that the laws
unconstitutional a violation of his
power powers commander chief
but no court has held that the law is on
the books
and he didn't follow well as well as far
as I know we thought something all the
constitution in this country even if we
don't pay that much attention to it
yet he had a signing statement but that
doesn't supersede the law
so that's what I want to talk about here
at does anyone care
about the law in effect yet like are we
still surprised that Obama broke the law
I mean what about
ordering a a drone strike on american
citizen without due process in secret
what about the I'm pretty
president warned whistleblowers what
about spying on the American people the
NSA
are counting dead military aged males
killed by drone strike that combatants
our site imeem
into law the in training up the
executive power
to indefinitely detain terror suspects
without trial
really worth the price get so well don't
give you took care for my whole point
yeah
sorry yeah that was perfect that would
prohibit that was my point that
we've done so much of this this you said
I'm you know it you're not surprised but
I don't need excuses that
I'm anything in this particular case
does really matter that congress got
approval
heavily not really because there would
probably agree with that anyway
so this particular his I don't really
think it matters I think the bigger
issue is that this keeps happening
and it's sad that we're not surprised
about it yes so President Obama did
issue
statement about this we have consulted
with congress for quite some time about
the possibility that we might need to
execute a prisoner exchange in order to
recover sergeant Bergdahl
we saw an opportunity we were concerned
about sargent Bergdahl's help
we had the cooperation up Qataris to
execute exchanger we see that
opportunity
at the process was truncated because we
wanted to make sure that we did not miss
that window
now what they are also saying is that
Bergdahl had some health issues
now he's being checked right now but the
it no one knows where he is exactly so
we haven't been able to verify that
there was some sorta
health issue that made this a you know
that they needed to have this happen
immediately
so even that statement like I get it
like he's like where we wanted to make
this happen wanna make a quick a
tentative
but again that doesn't super see the law
so should anyone
should we do anything about this it is I
think this is the type thing with the
media just gonna drop
and it's like I broke a log and depleted
a I think because it made strategic
sense we're not that upset about it
right
on but and I think the major issue is
that
the keeper he keeps breaking the law
this administration the former
administration keeps breaking the law
and a lot and it doesn't make sense and
we don't get an explanation
so I think bill that if we had more
trust in the government and stuff like
this when be more possible i think im
just really upset because this is just
another example
how the law is not followed and how we
are not given
information on at all you mentioned so
many things that although nothing
lol forgot about so all those things
when you add up all those things are
those
how do you think we're gonna look back
the Obama presidency
especially when it comes to be sorted
security issues and the spying in all
that like he really
in my opinion he's has has severely
dropped the ball here
well yeah but were sorta used to him
dropping the ball
but in this case I feel like we didn't
know so little about
a Bergdahl you know well
groupie deserter ready sick how many
people died looking for him
where is he now they're so that such a
lack of transparency break we'll
will remember for a long time would any
of that change your opinion on it if it
turned out that he was really sick and
they knew he had two weeks to live with
that
then mitigate you say well okay he can
go ahead a break books we want him back
for you guys I at the again I think in
this particular situation I'm not part
I'm not upset about the strategic yeah
in a move that was taken and they broke
the law because the law other men sort
of a safeguard their men to like guy do
you think what I can be broken
yeah I meant to be broken he has
something they don't make sense
I'm but the issue is that these laws
keep being broken when that we don't
have any information or any transparency
as you mentioned after why it makes
sense to break the law
yeah do you think the mainstream media
might be more upset about this
if it was say president bush well you
have to remember that present their
precious president reagan
them a little actually far worse forward
weapons to Iran
yeah and it was a huge failure and we
kinda forgot about that isn't he the
Messiah
love the Republican Party no right and
also people were saying well we don't
negotiate with terrorist threat that led
to another a run that began serving
throw thing right now
except we've done it with a passion this
was in negotiations with the prisoner
swap
which is different than negotiating with
Terry NASA
it's all right for everybody but not
exactly it may their
their get that so that the whole other
topic what we want more pressing
political stuff a friend of George
Clooney says
he might be jumping into the political
arena
we've got a quote he has big ambitions
and aims to get into politics
imminently he want to do more
humanitarian work in hopes to join the
democrats
2016 election campaign georgie thinking
about how he can get more involved
now he has a mile by his side it will
give him more credibility
to run for office a course this is a
friend of George Clooney's
could he obviously is no stranger to
politics he helped Obama get reelected
in 2012 he does a lot of political
fundraising
he's been involved in Darfur for he's
also married British lawyer amala mood
in
and she defended WikiLeaks Julian
Assange agency the Human Rights
specialist
so obviously he has interests that go
beyond just acting
and the reason I wanted to this story
because of course this is just
conjecture and it's one friend the thing
that
but I'm a firm believer that the way
everything heading in this country
we're gonna just start voting in
celebrities I mean hilary is already
becoming more of a celebrity than a
politician and Obama was sort of a a
celebrity
candidate I think that's the route is
going for better or worse
is is is boo net battered a good this
this celebrity
political mumbo jumbo think it depends
on the celebrity but I think it's an
issue when we take them one celebrity
status
or for for example under short shorts
mayors like
machos skills and you know power in
movies and transferred over to the real
world I think that the issue when we
assume
that these characters that they planned
television are actually part of who they
are
right so you want a torta de vere like
bust into the Capitol in Sacramento with
ok I'll meet you
big yeah I no
no I wanted him %uh released today yeah
I'm
but at different story I do think that
it kinda crazy how we
all about automatically attribute sort
of characteristics to celebrities and
assume that that to the I think that's
why people fall in love with celebrity
they don't realize that their
actors wreck so that's the part that i
think is really interesting about this
because if you look at me he looks
presidential right
people people like him he could play the
present very easily he played a
presidential candidate before
where would we leave it was called i'd
the March
did not see that one this occurred at
the open make awake from Turner Classic
Movies yeah
would you vote for honey would you were
coming home because on one hand
like he seems like he's on the right
side of things pro-gay rights
he did a lot of work for Darfur before
anyone else dead the other hand even
might be a little bit of an Obama crummy
like what happens when his idealism get
kinda question he surrounded by the
people that say you do this you do that
and he becomes a different man
the only thing is not strong enough I
mean
you work out more yeah about what I can
really funny about that quote was
it was kinda intimating like oh now he's
ready now that you don't have a wife
give the youth qualified right he's
getting this wife so said only if you
have a white then obviously
call me you can be present just to
clarify what I think earlier I don't
think that the celebrity thing
and politics is good like that net good
in general but I do think there's maybe
like a little room where
having people that are already rich and
already popular
maybe would be a little more honest
because they wouldn't be beholden
to all the all the corporate interest
maybe maybe a little bit I noticed that
before opening a bit as something it
sounds kinda gross
that the politicians who started at
celebrities and one
were conservative so I'm going to I
can't think I've are
al franken and what made it was an
actually john was going to
the act so she didn't maybe if not the
worst thing in the world
yeah do you guys think we need what they
have in most European countries
a president and a prime minister so one
the president that's where the celebrity
that there's all the ceremonial stuff
and then a prime minister that actually
does what are present like actually does
the work as I think that might help
if we were able to get some by the like
paparazzi stuff
of with the president and then have
someone else that was actually doing the
work to think that would help
i feel like i kinda happened already I
mean I don't assume that President
Obama's they're actually doing something
that you
old day it now I kid but on her I feel
like they probably and hot he probably
has a certain set of responsibilities
are
president does rain and then the other
day meet up right we don't think so much
of it is just going to the fundraiser
showing up at these events
as opposed to a work I think you agree
with me right
don't like absolutely a at the lot 1
percentage thing that they already kinda
Mia
tearing it up what he thinks we have a
president and a prime minister
and what are you were not a monarchy all
other than
yeah you know about oh wow it might be
I don't know about that I don't know
about that one day no now
now alright my crazy idea wanna turn
into a little more here
alright I'm not okay speaking at night
Google cars
mayor coming they are going to be felt
driving may not even have
steering wheel so in the car goes crazy
won't even have a chance people
but let's look at them spec from the
upcoming Google car
they're gonna have some interesting
safety measures like flexible windscreen
home like material the maximum speed for
now 25 miles per hour so you're not
taking a cross-country trip on this
thing
they'll be button for start and pull
over an emergency
topic anything crazy happen a course
sensors used for self-driving so that
they know
that there are it another one is cool
cars or a regular car
and feeling for two passengers we've
also got a little bit DOT
up with the cool cars gonna look like
here
here hard no steering wheel in
okay so starting in 2015 Google is going
to start using these cars in states that
permit
up four states right now allow the
the testing a self-driving cars on
public roads California Nevada
Florida and Florida and Michigan so I
guess the first thing is
would you trust these vehicles this
seems kinda crazy you're putting a lot
of bade
in the machine all effin people have
brought up before
you know what if your car gets hacked
what if someone over ride
your computer's if even if you have a
steering wheel you're still pretty
fucked in her wet
right I hate to break it to you I'm but
yeah there's a few things that are
accounted for here like what if you need
to
to wait for your you know grandma to get
out the car in the car what do you need
to go find parking
and a several stories tall parking
structure and untreated like
you know as being more than one story
dollar whether they're so many little
things like you like on accounted for
right logically just are kinda concerned
a little I mean
not fit not all situations can be
are I don't think it's ready yet you
know like what if any to park off road
yeah I don't wear anything our yeah I
think humans are running through is
ready I got I mean I know they don't
like studies at five thing years ago at
Stamford where they had driverless cars
and people freaked out granted been some
time since then
but still people are really incomparable
not being in control particularly a
moving object that the in our nature to
want to you
be in control of our feet and where we
move it makes no sense to be in a car
adding biologically our instinct tells
absolutely not right so before we fully
get to the hacking and all the evil
things that the machines are gonna do it
I think that
an interesting part of this that just
giving up the control
I mean just that just getting into this
thing and having fayed
that it's not going to get back into or
just something crazy
isn't gonna happen or someone else
that's driving because obviously we're
not going or change over I want someone
else is driving
normally is gonna just smack writing to
you anyway
you know at this place is a lot of
pieces here a good idea
all the cars are automated be great then
you know traffic could be cut down like
are getting food be cut down but when
you're still counting on half the time
like other people
ability to not crash into you and kill
you
its not incredibly fortuitous
nursery ethical concerns that like
involve having all
automated cars to the like for example
and me know that there could be a case
where
crash is inevitable that one car has
three people on the other car has one
percent what's the car do who should the
car protection to protect
you as they like our ownership that can
communicate with me and i i
that lol three people there say those
three lives and kill you like
there also so many questions really well
call is there a phrase for those laws
that robots are gonna have to a bye bye
like for my robot like that kind of
thing where they're gonna have to say
like oh there's three lives in this car
one just as you said and they're gonna
have to make decisions
you know the word I keep thinking prime
directive but I know that's not it
yeah about Star Trek I have other
concerns about Karzai when I was
watching this video
I kept thinking about this how did I get
in this taxi
but more open you down
lol yeah felt bad guys
three key that my point you're gonna
happen Johnny Cade going to be free get
people out
ion battery for a recall of course when
my favorite
I am 30 though it's so windy weather got
held in the study they found that if
they have a little tiny robot
yeah a little tiny robot in a driverless
car people are much more comfortable
yes i dnt do I would trust r2 d2
to control my vehicle I don't know that
I was JK but that even is interesting
because we still want some level of
human interaction there
which is why the when they when they
wrote that the maid
the guy looks sort of like but it's
scary that was far worse than having
about their
the okay so it's just that let's finish
up with the
with this machine's idea and the hacking
it all back anything
I mean if this step is inevitable that
shouldn't we be fighting anymore
should we be fighting it more you know
you mean we're all walk around with
these devices that can be hacked into
we're all we're gonna be in cars that
can be had to do all this stuff and if
you have a question
already be hacked into parts can be
hacked into now with OnStar
all now is the time to be forming
legislation or are some kinda
figuring out how what with the order the
thing is and how it should work and we
should understand how it all works for
that we're able to you
voice our opinions affectively rather
than it being OK
Eurotech tight were all I'm you're
saying that our politicians should have
foresight commit to things that we know
are coming and they should take
understand it what you're saying that he
is the population understand something
in our politicians should have
foresight to deal with it something
knowledge equals
good world yeah that's why you are very
alert
those crazy dirty thought with anyone
bring us home on it
I others like me a very but I was
thinking about
car ownership but how this can
potentially change that
how we may no longer oncars a baby comes
really cheap does have a driverless car
come pick about them I take as we have
to worry about insurance for gas
where somebody driving it might make
sense and that kinda exciting because I
feel like it'll lead to
lower carbon emissions way right sorry
we brought that surrounded not
necessarily the car apocalypse so I I
kinda feel good about that alright
let's talk about the NRA and no I'm not
talking about the National Rifle
Association i'm talking about.
the NRA the National Restaurant
Association which might be slightly more
dangerous believe it or not
this is a political lobby representing
the nation's largest
food service companies and they're one
of the most powerful
lobbyist on capitol hill they get a lot
of crazy
shit done let's take a look okay so they
have nearly 52,000 members and
this includes our guard in the Donald
Red Lobster Starbucks things like that
they have a PR firm berman company which
is famous for opposing sensible public
interest in safety was
a their leaders are in Fortune 500
companies
and they have a budget up sixty five
million dollars in a play for you up its
okay so I did space
nothing here sound that bad is just how
america works but
so there's a lot of information here so
you can pause it and read it on your own
but some other things that they've done
they depended pink slime in burgers
which we talked about
inhumane conditions for poultry they've
opposed industry pledges
to raise pigs humanely babe oppose
Paycheck Fairness Act for
waiters and waitresses Pregnancy
Discrimination Act and the block the
federal minimum wage increase
for restaurant employees they found a
loophole to exclude employees from the
new health care law
all kinda stuff I am and and there's a
lot more and I
nobody talk about this and you know we
talk about lobbying money about it all
the time
here but I thought this was thirty
interesting because he brings it
literally
to our table write the stuff that we're
putting in our body yeah
the step right there arm should be no
more
about the National Restaurant
Association did you know about this
before week's end you guys Martin Way
other I
in full disclosure word for Olive Garden
when I was in high school so I'll really
yeah I know I knew we were partly an RA
yeah other yeah name because we are so
38 NRA without a single loving
what is it that way like high night like
hiding in plain sight
right but was it wasn't you know the WWF
used to be the World Wrestling
Federation in the World Wildlife
Federation stepped in and then the WWF
the wrestling one
became World Wrestling Entertainment
resigning so should we force
with either an array to get another name
so we can all focus on them a little
understand them and no
get a good look at them the hasher yeah
week or move any any further
what we need to know about the unlimited
salad to the country right
light hours a day you know it the way he
what you know what
you can switch the felony you can switch
the super free
what you mean for what likely goin
limited soup salad and breadsticks
yeah I get like went up a solid and then
it still unlimited if you want to spend
it with these are a few won both the
minestrone
lol in Chile yes limited gonna a mini
wow %oh yeah
you well you know when you're here
either a been reported yeah there you go
I'm OK
had so yes so it shouldn't surprise us i
suppose that a lobbying
that a you know dissociation like this
would use lobbying to do all these
horrible thing
we shouldn't we know about this should
we be talking about why the never
discussed
it's funny because we we talk about the
stories like Papa John's opposing
and Obamacare and saying oh to cripple
is the
but then finding out it doesn't we think
I go I do it okay that I did Emily
overnight cool but what can we learn
there's that whole lobby
scouting are these ideas across the
industry
United one one billionaire yeah the
should the government why is the
government so involved in our
who isn't that like the bigger problem
here that we've so separate ourselves
from our food source you know you mean
we don't do any
kinda farm to table stop so that of
course you when you have all these
middlemen matter
a you know putting laws in that allow
for all these chemicals and all that
other stuff
and you the big question why the
government among our food
the necessary for survival I'm you know
in the same way that it's
involved in our here in keeping it clean
supposedly I'm
but it's also motherhood for profit
because it has a lot of corporate
interest to print acting mean look at
the dairy industry the something that
they get
agriculture it I'll at the place where
they
can make a lot of money and politicians
get a lot of money from these
corporations so it matters
than yeah so money in politics of course
among other things that I thought was
interesting
is that they bought against lower sodium
levels in food
which the generally they say lower
sodium in it for you
that's good that's why me wanna sell
more food and they won their product to
be tasty
oh so you're saying that the NRA is not
in it for public good
buried it for ice to buy more their shit
I mean are the unit with the top people
like you know to me like that just isn't
just one big clusterfuck
I know I'm sure if we look for their
will find that there is profit to be
had. in certain areas and that that's
why it's happening
would drive me crazy is that they were
fighting to keep tipped
server wages solo and two and fighting
the minimum wage increase
yeah I'm in other countries you know
liked it for what for the tipping think
yeah there
they're kinda they don't encourage
tipping
our it looked upon it at more you know
ago you think I would go to my job
yeah if it never something you cannot
overwrite prideful love you but you're
your work as a waiter yeah well speaking
about dad did you guys know that youtube
is gonna start putting a tip jar
right over there so and gets it what or
do it here
you could just it's not there yet I
don't think okay let's move on yeah
in 3d in they are gonna test out
something that is very
on American they want to see it working
less
well actually increase productivity
that's right the city government
Gothenburg Sweden
want to test the impact of shorter hours
and how that affects productivity in an
experiment
that begins in about three weeks so one
group government workers in the elderly
care sector are gonna work six hours a
day
while another organ worked for eight
hours that they're accustomed to working
after a year the government is going to
analyze the results and decide whether
the six-hour day
actually a allows people to accomplish
just as much as they were doing with two
extra hours
a course proponents of cutting the work
they are saying that you know people
have fewer
think the sick days and they'll be more
efficient in general
I and be international productivity
ranking by Conference Board
a non-profit business research
organization sweden was already
close to the top coming out 11 61
countries in terms of productivity
and we've got more info on that Korea
so it is average work hours and
international productivity rankings
okay so you can see here is that in the
Netherlands they don't work at time but
they're ranked fifth in productivity
pretty good
the United States we do work a lot an
average of be roughly 400 more hours a
year than they do in the Netherlands
and we are pretty please pretty good
interestingly in Chile and
in Mexico they worked her son and their
productivity is not good
so there's also order it a little all
over the place but also I think you can
get some
interesting stuff from this so it let's
just start with the the american
components were in america here
this is a very un-american right to say
oh you should work
or less and maybe that made me more
because we're just taught to work
and work and work to withdraw on working
hard working
mark so I player if you're tired and
you're hating life
yeah you're gonna work much more poorly
so I kinda
think think we didn't have a point here
yeah should we jump on this bandwagon
that's weird because I think when they
do that once they get the information
back on this legacy yeah
people can work more nimbly and more
swiftly
I think it it would be a great thing a
people work fewer hours because we were
good time a lot alike people are
independent contractors nowadays is one
there working more than 40 50 60 hours
we have a lot of young
lawyers that are going crazy 100 120
hour with work weeks
I think that unacceptable but I think
that if we are gonna lower the minimum
number of hours for full time work
from the a toothpick we all have to make
some changes so that
workers are engaged or getting the same
level of productivity
let me know that certain activities that
work lead
to you know lead to resultant others
don't
so that's where we should focus our
energy making people happy are more
engaged at work
so art first talk about happiness
because we never talk about that right
that that the one thing that never
talked about at is
the relation between work it happened so
they've done studies that show that
people that are working are generally
happier because then you have money and
you can go do things and take vacations
and things like that
but we don't really talk about it and so
do the day-to-day basis like where
happiness is coming from people I'm sure
that are working 100 hour work weeks
I know that have a direct now like your
family you're not sleeping enough you
know eating enough nothing your friend
you know getting things done that you
need to get done that already been fun
at all
yeah of course you're stressed out do
you guys think that as the economy
changes and now that we can do
everything online in computers and
things like that that you can accomplish
as much in three hours as maybe they
used to be able to accomplish all day
long so the I so I feel like a lot of
people right now
people to watch they're allowed to be
watching this at work we know it. a lot
of our videos are watched during work
hours
and people are at work without things to
do you actually because its order the
old paradigm
a like working nine to five but actually
you can accomplish all you need to do
from Mike nine to 11 that this idea
working to like from 925 come from like
the
the times on agriculture when we had to
wake up at a certain time
and then there was light and so we used
up all the valuable light time and then
we went to bed after the sunset or
whatever
that makes no sense to apply to like
today is society where we have
artificial light where we have the
Internet where we can communicate
globally
I think that what's happening though is
that because we have all these
technological advances
would want people to do more and yeah
bosses expect more out of us like now
like
I know and so many my friends tell me my
boss sent me an email at three o'clock
in the morning
an expected to respond only got fucking
output is inevitable that you get emails
about our don't you
records I see it all the time I get
emails I we got my check may not even
more now like
head out any other 10 or on the weekends
and get the expected response them like
fuck this like this is not OK
yet so is that the huge drawback to the
technology because now they're saying
how
it how people don't even stop working
when they're on vacation now because
everyone has
and iPhone and you can literally yeah on
the beach you're like oh shit
you know iPad yeah I love them
people like from work like a that
I different date now or
no but yeah I can definitely see this a
I feel like most of the work day is
spent you know hurry up and wait for
wasting time running out the clock
ever need to be that way we can enjoy
our lives shockingly enough and we can
enjoy our work
also talking we know yet so it's sweet
in which already as we said they
they don't work as much as us and they
are more productive if they find this to
be true and really push this idea all
over the country
do you think they're gonna have an
immigration problem I'm pretty sure
pretty sure they don't have the easiest
the immigration policies in the first
place but really you think this is with
the baby would be like you know what
they're doing something right here
different though to know they're very
much focused on education much more than
you know the US is and also how fear
they have a better educational system
they have about
better health systems I think those two
things also highly contribute to their
productivity
not just about the hours the fact that
they have a society where
even if they're working fewer hours or
so working great there you go
alright one more play let's talk about
condoms everybody left on them right
very the some new condom technology
that's right the Galactic cap which
claims to be stronger and safer than
traditional condoms
and enable better sensitivity we've got
an image
up the cap okay so what's happening here
should we put a a parental warning on
this video or graphic let it happen that
way very horrific a
sorry guys sorry lady I alright so this
babe Bailey like a tiny little
cap that goes on the top the penis the
refugee North
expose you to get more sensitivity
everyone in the city is really get the
cat is laying
I remember what are the parts were its
most sensitive though
at the Guyana tip but the now the
cabinet at the S and L
release NJ generally lower than the tip
but the temp
you know me below the tip
okay talk that they brought the no I
just the tip
yeah okay so because I don't make
compromises two-part you shape
polyurethane
adhesive film that wraps around the
penis that you saw their
it sorta like a plastic ran a finger and
a cap that sticks to firmly
crap the theme in so a guy basically
a could wear this all-time and be ready
for sex at any time a do you think men
would
ever women have to be on birth control
Iranian women didn't have taken
responsibility
for their reproductive health their
sexual many doesn't seem to me
would you able going to wear it for a
long time and I think it
Filho it now a 00
hey it might happen yeah everything
that's going to happen before he get
eight then they're gonna gonorrhea and
her bf because there's only protects
against pregnant the other than
protecting and any STD's so
right well I guess there's some question
whether it'll protect against sum up the
STD's because if it does crap you feel
it
it a strategy into the skin on skin
stuff so I could still do today some
questions related to that
but just to be a little clearer about
how this thing actually works for you
could literally
be wearing it all the time and then
would you want to have sex if you can
buy them at willing to do with you
I am not peel off the paper backing on
the cap
and stick it to the polyurethane to
secure the bond between
a
the yeah too but due to between the two
yeah you know cuz the penis is an organ
well known for always having the right
amount of friction and always being
dried
I'm sorry yeah I'm
I love them so that you can wear it all
the time anytime
I think it's crazy to think that a woman
will be like
oh you know for the first time you know
getting you know have the Pennine or
whatever and then alternately be petted
you don't hear that led to our baby
backing of it lookout Hill mean the Pens
are down anything you like bill call
up and also I'm thinking the Cupra
meditated this to change that with so
many others before me like
lol %uh not happening you're not getting
laid to beware that right and Ohio
so okay so for you guys if you were on a
date with a guy and then
you know you got back to back to his
place your place where your
and then it got naked and he already had
one of those are mine
not happening you be like what well
yellow you need to know you didn't know
when it waived
yeah but League yeah I like a you really
hung up on the
I know what I'm alright guys don't like
to
limited are you a little about
cleanliness
yeah no roads and dirty no you didn't
know that he detested appear gonna be
wearing that the plan
yeah like when alright well I guess I'm
gonna pass you my final question or two
which was do you think this kind will
finally revolutionise eight sex it
sounds like that happen to me
maybe in like a really committed
long-term relationships or whatever
we're like they the pill is giving you
like the girl
on an allergic reaction or morning
sickness like girls are fucking awful
so this is an alternative to using the
pill and the like committed monogamous
relationships are
yet but going back to what I said
earlier did is for guys it just seems
like guys just aren't responsible
another would you even would you even
trust the guy if there was something
that was really like that small
I mean would you trust him to you know
to me like you turn your head for that
bro you know he ripped that they gnaw
and you may not even know everybody
wanna do I want any prime network keep
he just may want more cities a shelf and
he's being so
well I think yeah with Parker I like you
you have so much baby man
that came to obey the men with that lot
of a pin meant
on that note do you have a panda let us
know in the comments down below click
LIKE subscribe
all that good stuff but you can catch
with that on the lip TV which is also on
the YouTube
and that Kim is on nerd alert which is
part a BTU 80% network I hope to get
you that already this point and the
barring electable
out with chemically your up